wasn't nervous at all it was really good
yeah
yeah so
you're part of a moment of history the
first to receive this vaccine
how does that feel it hasn't sunk in yet
i can't really answer that question yet
it's just really
i i don't know what to say it's just
only suppose really yeah
and what do you say to those who might
be having second thoughts about having
this well
i would say go for it go for it because
it's
it's free and it's the best thing that's
ever happened
uh at the moment so do please go for it
that's all i say
you know if i can do it well
so can you you know
happy birthday next week oh thank you so
much
thank you as i just said before
at the moment i don't know how i feel
it's just
just so strange and uh so wonderful
really
yeah so anyway
this is for a good cause so i'm so
pleased i had it done
yeah did you ever think in your whole
90 years you would ever be sitting here
the first person to have a
covet bathroom no never ever
does anything come close in your
lifetime to this moment
no i i can't think of anything
no not at all it's so so different
you know i this is a terrible total
disease so we do we do want rid of it
you know so
anything that helps it's a bonus isn't
it
really i don't know what else to say
really
okay what do your family make of you
being here today
well they don't mind at all they're all
for they're all for it
yes but um yes they are
you know they are for it yeah
so what will you do next you're going to
call your family and let them know
well i think i'll have a little rest
afterwards from the good
award and then i'll phone my family
i'm going home this afternoon so
that's that's it then so
and the hospital were really oh they
were wonderful so
i'm going to miss them really all the
attention i've been getting
i thought it was a joke to tell you the
truth to start with
i couldn't believe it you know but i'm
happy it's happened
and now i've done it and hopefully it'll
help
other people come along and they
do as i did you know try and
try and do the best for to get rid of
this terrible thing
yes what sort of year have you had
have you been personally affected by
coronavirus any members of your family
any of your loved ones no thank god no
no thankfully no
no no we're stuck by the rules
and we've got our own little bubble now
so you know we're doing
yes we have stuck by the rules so and as
you've been watching
the pandemic and you've seen the effects
i did and i did
how did that make you feel oh terrible
of what it's done to people you know
it's such so sudden and so
it's devastating to see what they're
going through really you know
so anyway okay everyone who wants to
know
how you're going to be celebrating your
birthday next week and
whether you're looking forward to
christmas now i i'm looking forward to
christmas
i didn't think i'd be getting home so
soon from hospital so
i'm spending christmas with a very small
men
four of my family members and then we'll
see what happens in the new year but i'm
just looking forward to christmas yes i
am
that's quite some birthday and the first
is birthing christmas comes together
more or less so
and i'm looking forward to both of them
i had my big birthday last year so
it can be a small family affair this
time